well Singapore is a very unique society
which is very hard to understand and I
can tell you the Western media gets it
completely wrong because you read the
Western media you got the impression
that Singapore is just a nicer version
of North Korea and everybody's
suppressed or pressed and so on so far
guess what you know virtually every
Singaporean travels overseas every year
and comes back to Singapore so obviously
this is not an office oppressive State
the reason why Singapore has
restrictions on press freedom is
precisely because of the 1964 ethnic
riots that Singapore experienced we've
seen in many other countries press
freedom like in Rwanda please to hate
speak against minorities we want to
ensure that that doesn't happen in
Singapore and therefore there are these
restrictions on press freedom in
Singapore but I know on the question of
civil liberties there's a very important
point that that Americans should bear in
mind when they speak about civil
liberties you know one of the big shocks
that the world experienced after 9/11
was when they watch America the world's
most advanced open democratic society
walked back from some civil entities as
soon as they began to feel insecure and
because they were frightened of
terrorists they said I'm happy to give
up my privacy
come have surveillance cameras
everywhere I'm not worried I want my
safety in security now if America the
world's most powerful country is
prepared to give up some of its civil
liberties in exchange for security right
then you begin to understand why smaller
and much more vulnerable states like
Singapore have also develop a compact
where the government is it okay we'll
give up some of our civil liberties
we'll give up some of our press freedom
but continue to keep this place peaceful
and prosperous and strong and Singapore
by the way is a small island city-state
of four million people who are primarily
Chinese surrounded by two neighbors
Malaysia in just 20 million people or 25
million people Indonesia which is 20
million people and both Malaysia and
Indonesia distrust their Chinese
minorities so if you live in that kind
of neighborhood right you got to make
sure that you remain very strong and
discipline and that's what Singapore
needs for survival
yes because because the if you've had a
successful track record if these
limitations have not damaged you in any
way and by the way the there's
absolutely no restrictions and flow of
information Singapore by the way is much
more connected to the broadband than
Americans are the Internet is everywhere
in Singapore you can get information on
anything you want in in in Singapore so
believe me there's in Singapore by the
way can only become a leading financial
center if it remains completely open to
flows of information and we and and
that's why Singapore succeeding so there
are the flows of information in
Singapore the restrictions about what
you report on domestic politics and on
what you report on the race situation
Singapore but otherwise there's no other
restrictions in Singapore on
you